elle est extrêmement populaire notamment
parmi les adolescents tik tok la
plateforme de partage de vidéos du
groupe chinois baic dance revendique un
milliard d'utilisateurs actifs et son
application a été téléchargée 315
millions de fois au premier trimestre de
l'année 2020 mais elle ne semble pas
conquérir les sénateurs républicains aux
états unis le 29 juillet dernier en
petit groupe d'entre eux a demandé par
lettre à l'administration montrent up
d'enquêter sur tik tok
il estime que la chine pourrait s'en
servir pour espionner ses utilisateurs
mais aussi pour interférer dans
l'élection présidentielle en novembre
nous sommes très préoccupés par le fait
que le parti communiste chinois puissent
se servir de son contrôle sur tik tok
pour déformer ou manipuler les discours
politiques afin de semer la discorde
parmi les américains et d'obtenir le
résultat qu'il escompte techtoc est donc
sous le coup d'une enquête du ca fille
us le comité sur les investissements
étrangers aux etats-unis est une agence
chargée d'examiner les investissements
étrangers
elle s'assure que ces derniers ne
représentent pas de menaces pour la
sécurité nationale
tik tok fait l'objet d'une enquête du ca
fille us nous ferons une recommandation
au président cette semaine afin d'avoir
un maximum d'options donald trump avait
évoqué début juillet l'idée de bannir
tik tok du cyberespace américain de son
côté l'entreprise chinoise dont la
filiale aux états unis est dirigée par
un américain affirme n'avoir aucun lien
avec les autorités chinoises
elle est dirigée par un pdg américain
avec des centaines d'employés et de
cadres
ici aux etats unis nous n'avons jamais
fourni de données sur les utilisateurs
au gouvernement chinois et nous ne le
ferions pas si cela nous était demandé
la défense de tik tok ne semble pas
convaincre aux états unis cette semaine
la directrice de campagne du candidat
démocrate joe biden a appelé toute son
équipe à désinstaller l'application même
décision en décembre dernier de la part
de l' us navy pour ces marins tik tok a
déjà fait les frais des tensions entre
la chine et divers pays
c'est le cas de l'inde qui a décidé de
la bannir pour des raisons de sécurité
nationale selon le gouvernement pas
d'inquiétude cependant pour les
utilisateurs français dans l'hexagone
l'une des dernières personnalités à
s'être créé un conte tictoc n'est autre
qu emmanuel macron